Going to therapy is probably one of the most common ways the average person sees a psychologist at work. Some museums are trying to change that. A program called the Living Laboratory is breaking down the barriers between psychological scientists and the public by having museum visitors and their children see and participate in actual psychological experiments. And it's become a learning experience for the participants and the scientists. I'm Audrey Hamilton and this is Speaking of Psychology. Peter Blake is an assistant professor of psychology and director of the social development and learning lab at Boston University. He studies how children learn to become cooperative members of society.
去看心理医生可能是普通人接触心理学家工作的最常见方式之一。一些博物馆正试图改变这种现状。一个名为“活实验室”的项目打破了心理科学家与公众之间的壁垒，通过让博物馆参观者及其儿童观看并参与实际的心理学实验。这已经成为参与者和科学家的共同学习体验。我是奥德里·汉密尔顿，欢迎收听《心理学讲堂》。彼得·布莱克是波士顿大学心理学助理教授、社会发展与学习实验室主任。他研究儿童如何学会成为社会的合作成员。
Specifically, he uses experiments to investigate children's altruism, fairness, and other social behaviors in different cultures. Over the last 10 years, he's worked to bring the lab to the general public by collaborating with the Boston Museum of Science as part of the Living Laboratory, a nationwide program that aims to help grown-ups understand children's development by a university. immersing museum visitors in the process of scientific discovery. Welcome, Dr. Blake. Hello. Let's talk about the living laboratory at the Museum of Science. From what I understand, psychologists are working in museums, conducting experiments with volunteers.
具体来说，他通过实验来调查儿童在不同文化中的利他主义、公平感和其他社会行为。在过去的10年里，他通过与波士顿科学博物馆合作，将实验室带给普通大众。这是“活实验室”全国性项目的一部分，该项目旨在通过让博物馆参观者沉浸在科学发现的过程中，帮助成年人了解儿童的发展。欢迎您，布莱克博士。您好。让我们来谈谈科学博物馆里的活实验室。据我所知，心理学家们正在博物馆里工作，与志愿者一起进行实验。
It's fascinating. What was the idea behind this project and how does it work? Researchers in the Boston area, there's a lot of psychology labs around here. we were interested in where we could get subjects, particularly developmental psychologists are always looking for new populations of children or access to children and families that we can test. And the Museum of Science was interested in having scientists come into the museum and explain what they're doing to parents and their children as well. So about 10, probably more than 10 years ago at this point, there was a meeting of the minds, and we agreed to start doing research at this one area of the Museum of Science in Boston. And this, over several years, this grew into a more formal program that is specifically about,
这太迷人了。这个项目背后的想法是什么？它是如何运作的？波士顿地区的研讨人员，这里有很多心理实验室。我们对在哪里能找到受试者很感兴趣，尤其是发展心理学家总是在寻找新的儿童群体，或者寻找能够测试的儿童和家庭。科学博物馆也对让科学家来到博物馆向父母和儿童解释他们在做什么很感兴趣。因此，大约在10年，甚至可能是10多年前，各方思想碰撞，我们同意在波士顿科学博物馆的这个区域开始进行研究。多年来，这发展成了一个更加正式的项目，专门关于，
not just about us collecting data, but also about scientists engaging. in education with the public. So it's kind of a research education collaborative. And we've developed this, and it's become more clearly defined, and now it's kind of a, there's a shared value system that we have in working with the Museum of Science. So I can go into more detail on some of that, if you like. Yeah, I mean, the psychological experiments,
不仅仅是我们收集数据，还关乎科学家参与公众教育。所以这有点像一个研究与教育的协作项目。我们已经发展了这个项目，它变得更加明确，现在它在与科学博物馆的合作中有一种共同的价值观体系。如果你愿意，我可以对此作更详细的介绍。是的，我的意思是，心理学实验，
they appear to be a good fit for these types of venues. And you've conducted, like you said, research in these museums. Can you tell us about some of those experiments and what you found? Yeah, absolutely. So we do things, we have to design our experiments specifically for this kind of environment, but in the museum environment, it's actually quite similar to running experiments in preschools or in elementary schools. This is something that developmental psychologists have done for generations. So that's a standard practice. But we don't run the studies. The studies can't be an hour long, for example. That's kind of rare. We have to be sensitive to the fact that parents are there with their kids. They want to get some experience. They are interested in the science of what we're doing. Here's an opportunity for their kids to do an experiment, and it'll only take maybe 10 minutes.
它们似乎非常适合这类场所。就像你说的，你已经在这些博物馆里进行了研究。你能给我们讲讲其中一些实验以及你们发现了什么吗？是的，绝对可以。所以我们做的事情，我们必须专门为这种环境设计实验，但在博物馆环境中，这实际上与在幼儿园或小学里运行实验非常相似。这是几代发展心理学家一直在做的事情。所以这是一个标准做法。但我们不运行那些研究。例如，研究不能长达一个小时。这有点罕见。我们必须考虑到父母和他们的孩子在一起的事实。他们想获得一些体验。他们对我们所做事情的科学性很感兴趣。这里是他们的孩子做一个实验的机会，而且可能只花大约10分钟。
So it's a very safe way for parents to get engaged in the process. parents are always interested in how their kids are thinking and how they behave. So this is something they're eager to participate in. The kinds of experiments that I've been doing specifically, kids really enjoy them because they usually get some sort of prize. For altruism, for example, we'll give kids a set of stickers and we'll tell them that you can keep them all for yourself or you can give some to another child. And this basic setup when it's done by economists, the idea is that the child gets to act as a dictator. They get to make a decision about what they're going to get and what this other child is going to get. Giving is costly.
因此，对于父母来说，这是一种非常安全的方式，可以参与到这个过程中。父母总是对他们的孩子如何思考以及他们的行为方式感兴趣。所以这是他们渴望参与的事情。我具体做过的那些实验，孩子们真的很喜欢，因为他们通常能得到某种奖品。例如，关于利他主义，我们会给孩子们一套贴纸，并告诉他们你可以把它们全部留给自己，或者你可以给另一个孩子一些。当经济学家这样做时，这种基本设置的想法是，儿童充当独裁者。他们可以就他们将得到什么以及另一个孩子将得到什么做出决定。给予是有代价的。
So this is a behavior that has some consequences for them. And this works really well in the Museum of Science. We can do this quickly. And we've been able to compare the results there to what we get in the lab, what we get in schools, and in other settings. And so far, everything looks very consistent. So that's one very simple basic game. And what we've done over time, now once we establish that, the basic result is that children who are younger
因此，这是一种对他们产生一定影响的行为。这在科学博物馆里效果非常好。我们可以快速完成。而且我们能够将那里的结果与我们在实验室、学校和其他环境中得到的结果进行比较。到目前为止，一切看起来都非常一致。所以这是一个非常简单基本的博弈。随着时间推移，我们所做的是，一旦我们确定了这一点，基本结果是儿童年龄较小，
than about six years of age will keep more than for themselves in that setup and a baseline. And then they tend to approach giving an equal split as they get closer to six, seven, and eight. So what we've done with that and what other researchers now do quite regularly, we use that giving measure as our dependent experimental manipulation before that are different conditions and see if we can increase or decrease children's giving. So in that way, we can study what are the factors that help children engage in more altruistic behavior and what can depression? And I'm sure a lot of parents find that very interesting.
小于大约6岁的儿童在该设置和基线中会为自己保留更多。然后随着他们接近6岁、7岁和8岁，他们往往会接近平分。因此，我们用它做了什么以及其他研究人员现在经常做什么，我们使用这个给予测量作为我们的因变量实验操作，在此之前有不同的条件，看看我们是否能增加或减少儿童的给予。通过这种方式，我们可以研究帮助儿童参与更多利他行为的因素是什么，以及什么可以抑制？我确信很多父母觉得这非常有趣。
I mean, they want to know how do I make my child a more giving child, a more kind child, maybe a more empathetic child. So how do they react when you get them involved, them and their children? You know, what do they get out of this experience? So that's one of the great things about this environment is that we recruit the parents right there. We get their consent. The child participates in our setup. The parents can watch what the child does. We ask them not to interfere, obviously.
我的意思是，他们想知道如何让我的孩子成为一个更慷慨的孩子，一个更善良的孩子，也许是一个更有同理心的孩子。那么，当你让他们、他们和他们的孩子参与进来时，他们作何反应？你知道，他们从这次经历中得到了什么？所以这是这个环境的伟大之处之一，我们在现场招募父母。我们得到他们的同意。孩子参与我们的设置。父母可以观看孩子做什么。显然，我们要求他们不要干涉。
And then we can talk to them right afterwards about what just happened. And for the altruism games, children are often quite selfish and parents are often a little bit surprised or embarrassed. But at least to some great conversations about like, oh, this really, you know, surprise. Like, yeah, this is completely typical. You know, we always have to consider that this is a, you know, we can't make a prediction for your particular child. But we do have a general sense of what are the factors that can cause, cause children to be more altruistic under different conditions. And we also have an opportunity to explain a bit of the science.
然后我们可以在事后立即与他们讨论刚刚发生了什么。对于利他主义游戏，孩子们往往相当自私，父母通常有点惊讶或尴尬。但这至少带来了一些很棒的对话，比如，哦，这真的，你知道，惊喜。就像，是的，这完全是典型的。你知道，我们总是必须考虑到这是一个，你知道，我们无法为你的特定孩子做出预测。但我们对在不同条件下导致儿童更加利他的一些因素有一个总体概念。我们也有机会解释一点科学。
We typically will run our conditions as between subjects' conditions. And that just means that children are only received one experimental manipulation. So parents who are watching this just see that their child did a search task or something before this. And they're like, well, isn't that? the thing that's driving the effect. And like, well, we can only tell that if we compare it to a control condition where they're doing some other kind of task. So it gives us a chance to explain to the parents what our science is about.
我们通常会将我们的条件作为被试间条件来运行。这仅仅意味着儿童只接受了一种实验操作。因此，正在观看这一过程的父母会看到他们的孩子在做搜索任务或在此之前的某些事情。他们会想，难道不是那个东西在驱动效应吗？就像，好吧，只有当我们把它与他们正在做某种其他任务的控制条件进行比较时，我们才能知道这一点。因此，这给了我们一个向父母解释我们的科学是关于什么的机会。
And I guess this leads into my next question. You know, why not? It sounds like this is not only educational for the parents, even maybe some of the children, but for you, the researchers, you know, you're out of a controlled laboratory setting. in a dynamic setting. I mean, what are the advantages of that? Yeah, this has been a real learning experience for everyone who's been involved in the learning lab project. And one of the benefits to the researchers, kind of initially an unexpected benefit and a bit of a challenge, was that we were forced to really find ways to explain our studies to parents and to other people
我想这也引出了我的下一个问题。你知道，为什么不呢？听起来这不仅对父母有教育意义，甚至可能对一些孩子也有教育意义，而且对你们这些研究人员来说，你知道，你们离开了受控的实验室环境，进入了一个动态的环境。我的意思是，这有什么优势？是的，这对参与“活实验室”项目的每个人来说都是一次真正的学习体验。对研究人员的好处之一，起初是一个意想不到的好处也是一个挑战，那就是我们被迫真正找到向父母和其他人解释我们研究的方法，
who are present quickly, quickly, clearly, and truthfully, accurately. And so this is something where, as we worked, the researchers worked with the educators at the Museum of Science, we learned a lot from them because this is what they do. That's what they do. So they're like, okay, well, if you explain your study to me, you know, I'll give you advice on how you might want to present it to the public. And that helps to take the jargon out of it and present things in a clear way with examples. So that's been one of the benefits, and now we push it down to, we have our, I have my graduate students go and run this.
在场的人快速、清晰、真实、准确。因此，随着研究人员与科学博物馆的教育工作者合作，我们向他们学到了很多东西，因为这就是他们的工作。这就是他们所做的。所以他们会说，好吧，如果你向我解释你的研究，你知道，我会就你如何向公众展示它提出建议。这有助于去除其中的行话，并用清晰的例子展示事物。所以这是好处之一，现在我们把它推行下去，我们让我的研究生去运行这个。
And as part of it, they have to come up with explanations. Often a parent really just wants to hear like the two-second version, and that's fine. But you have to be able to say, like, so this is what we're doing. this is what, you know, we found in the past. That's great, see you later. But then another parent, you know, they might say, well, tell me more. So now you have the three-minute version. And this can expand into, like, different levels of discussion.
作为其中的一部分，他们必须想出解释。通常，父母真的只想听到两秒钟的版本，这很好。但你必须能够说，所以这就是我们在做的。这就是，你知道，我们过去发现的。太棒了，再见。但接着另一位父母，你知道，他们可能会说，好吧，告诉我更多。所以现在你有了三分钟的版本。这可以扩展到不同水平的讨论。
And each of those levels of communication has to be correct, right? So this is often a bit of a challenge. One of the ways that the museum has helped us do this is they create handouts. It's just a two-side, very small thing. that we can hand to parents that says, this is what it's about, this is what we found in the past, and here are some things you can try at home to play around with this idea with your own child. These aren't things, you know, what you do at home. That's not something I usually think about.
并且每一个水平的交流都必须是正确的，对吧？所以这通常有点挑战。博物馆帮助我们做到这一点的方法之一是他们创建讲义。这只是一份两面的、非常小的东西，我们可以递给父母，上面写着，这就是它的内容，这是我们过去发现的，这里有一些你可以在家里尝试的事情，和你的孩子一起玩这个想法。这些不是事情，你知道，你在家里做什么。这不是我通常会想的事情。
Right. So it really challenges us to come up with ways to convey why this is important and interesting. Do you think it's getting psychology and the idea of psychology as a science out there to the general public as well? One way we convey that it's a science is by explaining, like, this is an experiment with different conditions. That seems to impress on people that we're doing something scientific. And we also, this sounds very silly, but like one thing that we mention is that, yes, we run statistics real effect. And just adding the math piece seems to give some legitimacy that like, oh, okay, and interpreting them, you're actually have quantitative measures and are doing. math. That seems to impress upon people that are like, oh, okay, that might be a science then.
对。所以它确实挑战我们想出方法来传达为什么这很重要且有趣。你认为这是否也将心理学以及心理学作为一门科学的概念传达给了广大公众？我们传达它是一门科学的一种方式是解释，这是一个具有不同条件的实验。这似乎给人们留下了深刻的印象，即我们正在做一些科学的事情。而且我们还，这听起来很傻，但比如我们提到的一个事情是，是的，我们运行统计学真实效应。仅仅添加数学部分似乎就赋予了一些合法性，即，哦，好吧，在解释它们时，你实际上有定量测量并且在做数学。这似乎给人们留下了深刻的印象，他们会觉得，哦，好吧，那可能是一门科学。
Well, it seems to be doing really well. There are more than 25 living laboratories and museums across the country. I mean, what does the future look like for these types of programs? It's really, it has grown rapidly due to a large NSF grant that the Museum of Science got to spread this. And it's spread beyond. There are 20,000. 25 living laboratories, but a lot of other research labs have set up their own independent, have explored independent connections with museums as well. And to give you one striking example, one of my colleagues that I started doing this work with the Museum of Science, Andrew Barron, who's at University of British Columbia,
嗯，它似乎做得很好。全国有25个以上的活实验室和博物馆。我的意思是，这些类型的项目的未来是什么样的？由于科学博物馆获得了一笔用于推广的大型NSF（美国国家科学基金会）资助，它确实迅速增长。并且它已经超出了这个范围。有2万个。25个活实验室，但许多其他研究实验室也建立了自己的独立机构，探索了与博物馆的独立联系。举一个引人注目的例子，我和他一起在科学博物馆开始这项工作的同事之一，安德鲁·巴伦，他在不列颠哥伦比亚大学，
when he moved up there, he set up his own relationship with the museum. museum in Vancouver. He told us that he's been testing thousands of kids a year. Wow. So it's become a real, I don't like to say it's a gold mine, because that really emphasizes just the data collection aspect. But it's been a very beneficial and productive relationship for both sides, I think. Well, great, Dr. Blake. This has been very fascinating. Thanks so much for joining us. Thank you.
当他搬到那里时，他与温哥华的博物馆建立了联系。他告诉我们，他每年测试数千名儿童。哇。所以这已经成为一个真正的，我不想说这是一座金矿，因为那真的只强调了数据收集方面。但对双方来说，这都是一个非常互利且富有成效的关系，我认为。好吧，太棒了，布莱克博士。这非常迷人。非常感谢你加入我们。谢谢你。
Thanks for listening. To hear more episodes and to learn more about the Living Laboratory, go to our website at speakingofpsychology.org. With the American Psychological Association, Speaking of Psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听。要收听更多剧集并了解有关活实验室的更多信息，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。携手美国心理学会，《心理学讲堂》，我是奥德里·汉密尔顿。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。